so yeah I guess so this is like the last
of the day i guess so i guess some of
you might be like very tire in a light
that kind of thing and I'm like in
between you know the this like now and
the next section which is like live
music j/s connecting I'm sure you guys
are like very excited about music and
JavaScript right so kind of like you
know unlike start in between so anyway
I'm a yawn hello welcome to Singapore
for some of you guys and then I guess
you know if you look at my twitter
account you know i'm i'm cheon you know
should totally follow me I do a lot of
stuff I do a lot of things and I
organized a lot of things so if you look
at my avatar right like so it's like
kind of a crop because like we do a lot
of square and then down there is
actually a selfie coffee so I'm like
drinking my own face yeah so it's pretty
weird yeah it's kind of cool at the same
time so they print disc your face on the
coffee and then you just drink it and
yeah it can be both cold or hot which is
kind of nice and you know if you want to
go to space ask me later it's a nice
cafe and some of you might have seen on
TV which is kind of weird I have to
speak mandarin i'm not really good in
speaking Mandarin even though I'm
Chinese but yeah some of you might yeah
this is like on TV interview kind of
thing some of you might have seen me on
a really huge slide my god yeah so so
this is dr. yeah Ibrahim he's like the
minister of communications and something
some very important like
in Singapore so and then somehow you
just put my face on that huge slide and
then that's like my my colleague I said
wow I'm chance so big yeah it's a pretty
weird comment so I'm from Penang you
know a place where all the good food are
in Malaysia and then I kind of like work
and study in KL for like four years and
I'm here in Singapore for like roughly
seven years so I'm quite kind of like
you know like feels very local here yeah
and yeah so I'm supposed to be giving a
technical talk since the beginning of a
year and then suddenly Thomas like Kylie
tell me to like hey you know you should
give a like a community talk you know
like last talk of the day community top
I'm like yeah cool cool cool yeah
perhaps I should do that you know like
and then he invented this wood called
self reflect ability not sure if it
exists in the dictionary or anything but
yeah it's kind of you know
self-reflection so the reason why I
think why Thomas asked me that because
I've been kind of like if you look at my
site this is like my blog archives so
I've been writing a lot of for this year
so this year is kind of like a year that
changes me a lot so I all I change a lot
yeah so I don't really write a lot kind
of i write once a year which is weird
but yeah kind of cool and then this year
I'm like whoa like building stuff blah
blah blah you know like designing stuff
and i'll be building so many things and
write all of them down all my procedures
all my whatever you know details that I
can you know right out and now you might
notice that on the third blog post is
called being invisible so this is like
the the article that article that I
write their kind of light changes the
people around me as and also myself so I
don't expect you guys to read this right
now because you probably take like 30
minutes it took me two years to write
this
and actually publish this I have the
courage to publish it yeah so basically
you know I'm this the article about
myself being invisible being ignored
being a nobody and I'm sure that some of
you might might think the same way as
well and don't worry am i'm watching so
I also built a website called like a
website with a project called life where
it's kind of like I document i kinda
like open source my life so not only
that I open source my thinking and my
feelings and stuff I also open source my
whole like events in my life kinda looks
like this so i registered life it was
pretty cool don't mean you know like
top-level domain called life so it's
like Cian that life so you can register
if you'll be like this for that or would
yeah so yeah so it's just time lines of
importing events it's pretty cool you
know like cuz as I grow older I start to
forget things you know in my previous
life you years so disclaimer this is not
a technical top there's no codes on
these slides so no not really very
JavaScript related mostly jazz you know
just non technical stuff so you know
don't echo it's okay no worries but I'd
like to tell stories so this is like my
style of giving talks so i really like
telling stories for some reason but yeah
kind of yeah anyway but first let's look
at photos so yeah just all this morning
Thomas I show this photo you know yeah
this is like the typical group photo
kind of thing right and then every time
you see like oh group photo and up here
like photo of a group of people this is
like branch SG it's a local Singapore
meetup where it's not real meet up it's
like a hang out of pique off like like
people of engineers designers and makers
and anyone curious about the whole you
know tech people in Singapore and we
just hang out in a cafe and and talk
basically we don't really talk about
that go stuff sometimes you just talk
about life and stuff so it's kind of
cool you know like this there's no
setting there's no agenda there's no
speakers there's no like free food you
just go and get food yourself so this is
like two years ago pretty random you
know like just grabbing all these tables
and chairs and combine it together and
then we just sit and talk and this is
okay cool so whenever I look at photos
of people it reminds me of photos of
like you know when I go to school and
then my teacher was tell me hey let's
take a group photo and I'm like oh okay
yeah now I know why you're likely right
you know in school sometimes you take
group photos and if you look at that
that radar is me so it's kind of is
always this kind of setting and every
time I look at group of like the photo
of like group people it always reminds
me like Kyle I ok so i watch any me a
lot and usually this this kind of thing
is always reminds me of so many things
it reminds me of this reminds me of
school reminds me of things I watch like
most of my time so but what does this
mean right like it's just a photo and
and that's when you know like that's
when you know sometimes we have to start
for a while and I think why we do all
these things right why do we take group
photos in the first place why do we you
know go like to a place together and do
all these things together and I kind of
I want to begin with the beginning with
this wheel and begin the beginning so
basically start from scratch again like
why we do this in the first place so
this is like my story on how I get
started so first I would like to mention
this guy yeah so Chris Neil I'm sure you
guys don't know about this is this
person yeah so Chris Neil is like
all right there like first internet
stranger who helped me so I'll never
forget this guy basically because I
literally he's like the first person on
the internet who actually like help me
doing stuff like I I push something on
internet like you know like upload
something on internet did something
wrong and he helped me fix it I'm like
wow like why why did he help me you know
I don't even know how it looks like I
don't even know his real name actually I
don't even know where he is strong like
seriously like ah and at that time he
you know like time people don't really
put their real names they always put
their user names like so he's user names
actually CDN and I don't even know what
CDN mins yes so is this light looks like
a fish so if aunt you know I still don't
know how he looks like but he kind of
like you know changed my thinking like
why would anyone actually help me like
that kind of thing like a stranger
actually helped me like I didn't even
ask for help but that moment was like
really special for me and it's kind of
like you know if let's say you're on the
street and then like you fall down and
someone help you you can see the person
who helped you write but on the internet
I couldn't even see the face like
seriously okay I don't even know know
like who is this guy and always from
stuff like that and it's kinda like you
know started the whole thing about why I
you know like why I keep asking why and
and this is the other guy David tensor
he is the first person inspire me on
like UI design and stuff so basically so
that's when I got started on like
learning how to design stuff learning
illustrator learning Photoshop learning
everything basically you know it's just
it's just always this starting part like
people who inspire you and then you just
start doing things and then it just
happens and then anyone remembers this
obviously this is not CSS comp so yeah
but anyway so CSS H is the first website
that inspires me to learn CSS and no I
never forget this and that first demo
the complex spiral demo is so cool like
seriously so cool at that time it's kind
of like it's a background image CSS
technique carding now it looks kind of
plain kind of you know not so special
anymore but at that time is like a
website that inspires myself inspired me
and also a lot of other people and then
that's yeah the support is also one of
the sites that inspired me a lot of
articles not just about CSS but also
about JavaScript web development
everything and it looks kind of kind of
kind of kind of weird now but yeah it's
pretty clear that time it's like the
colors and all that stuff so and then so
it's not just like website you know
they're not just about people it's also
about the website sometimes you are
inspired by all these things and then
I'm also inspired by this guy come off
virus not sure if you look guys yeah so
here's the first person encouraged me to
give talks so actually he didn't
encourage me to give talks he actually
trick me into giving a talk which is
anything so I was like I just graduated
and I tell me that Oh first time going
to a conference you must give a talk mas
I'm like okay cool cool I give a talk
and then it will start to know me I'm
like oh that's pretty cool you know and
then the experience is really really
nice you know like first time is very
very nervous and I'll like I'm nervous
now but yeah it's kind of a cool but
that first time means a lot to me and
then there's always that first time of
like that someone would teach me how to
code and Ginny she teach me how to cool
it last time and I still remember that
you know like i was asking also emailing
her about like this piece of code this
very newbie piece of code is just an
if-else statement
I just I'm just asking her like is this
is if else statement correct and then
she told me that yeah it's correct you
know like you're doing it the right way
and and her company when really changes
like really like color changes me and
kind of like inspire me like wow like
someone's so good in like engineering
and so clean programming actually
praises my coat and says that I'm doing
the right thing and it's just my first
try and it would and that itself I like
you know these people have changed my
life kind of like for my career they
have inspired me and they have done this
little things that makes me wonder what
makes you want to do what I'm doing
right now and you know like I don't know
why I want to be like them because they
are so cool you know like they inspire
me and a one to be like them I don't
know why I just want so I kind I do a
lot of things I attend a lot meetups I
didn't yeah I'm like usually the ones
who like just go through meetups and I
don't even know why I go yeah it's kind
of weird and I do a lot of app so i just
keep on building and building and doing
a lot of stuff and learn a lot of things
and the usuals blog post and if talks
sometimes not a lot yeah and then
sometimes he like for the past three
years I kind of like embark on a journey
I feel kind of like you know I've been
doing these things for that the past few
years in Singapore like seven years and
then one year in KL so I was working for
for the past eight years and i kinda
like ah man you know perhaps I should
try to see what's outside you know like
I feel like I like trap in this place so
so if you see carefully uh in my life
website my giant life I could I
documented my
booth and I kind of like you know like I
think it's time to get out you know you
can see the years and the age so turn 14
I went to a lot of a lot of conferences
so I'm like like ambicom really become
which is a ruby conference by the way I
don't really do Ruby by go anyway I
don't know why but ya RAB directions off
everything done 15 also go to a lot of
conferences and obviously CSS car GS com
is always yeah yeah I'm pretty loyal
today this year I kind of tone down a
bit I go to more local well not look
yeah singapore conferences I even go to
like start up conferences like Tunisia
conference the actual and these are like
startup kind of conference where like
people that found us investors go and
for some reason I go to PHP cough and
iOS conf hmm i don't even do a PHP or
iOS yeah and people ask me like whoa
what do you do front end yeah so I'm
like cool you don't do io SI ya so it's
kind of funny and obviously if you count
like this GS com and oh yeah November so
anyway so yeah this year included so
past years I've been going to a lot of
conferences I don't know why and if you
minus 120 for conferences I did not
speak in any of those conferences I'm
just an attendee I just I'm just like
you guys sitting at the back looking at
the speaker and now I'm like oh this is
so weird I'm not looking bad on the
other side of this thing so it's kind of
funny so I'm just go to places you know
and I even blog about why I attend
conferences in after a while I kind of
like Oh finally I get it you know like I
finally get why people go to conferences
I finally get the reason you know all
the secrets all the tips and tricks on
good conferences and then so I kind of
like you know learn a lot of things
I learned a lot of things I asked a lot
of questions and this is pretty cool you
know like when you go to a lot of this
place these conferences or meet ups for
like the past few years you start to
know more things while I started no more
things I find out how people organize
conferences and events and meetups I
realized that there's so many little
details that most of us don't really
know and it's kind of cool you know like
obviously you know if you go to this
event you start to get to know more
people and then you ask them questions
ask them where do they work where do you
leave you know like all these questions
will start to get quite personal
sometimes and that's pretty cool you
know like and you know and there are few
people who are like to mention which is
versus okay cyanea cyanea is a one of
the very popular people in in Singapore
I mean popular figure in Singapore so
she built a website called vsg obviously
some of you might know is basically like
I call this like a like a engineer thing
like when you see a problem you want to
solve it so she kind of like see a
problem in the let people come Singapore
and they don't know what events are
there so there's no like aggregated to
have all events and then just like okay
let's build a website and I will get all
the events it's that simple you know
like basically it's just a website with
events listed for like the next few days
that's it and also like repositories of
github repositories of people contribute
to stuff in Singapore and then after
that you know she even built like you
know after all these years of
aggregating all the state or she build
this website called data that we build a
nice tree which is like a historical
data of everything of all the events in
Singapore and all that stuff you can
play around with it and then a second
person is michael chang you know this is
like a must know guy if you're in
singapore you must really know him so
he's like the organizer of PHP cough and
he does crazy things
so he created this website called energy
as the SG so engineer say is when you
look at it it's just a web site of
videos right like you know it's like
YouTube yeah but if you see carefully
right these are recordings of talks of
meetups it's kinda like recording so
every single top in almost every single
meet up in Singapore so there's like a
thousand two hundred and forty-one
videos and what do these videos come
from well he recorded himself and that's
that's crazy like but now it's much
better because he finally like got some
volunteers to help him but I think he
used to like do this by himself so kind
of like that's a lot of work just to
help other people you know like so it's
also like an engineer thing you see a
problem you want to solve it so most
people come to Singapore do say that hey
you know you got a lot of meetups but
like how do I see the videos of the
previous speakers like I don't even know
like who actually speaks you know that
kind of thing so Michael kind of like
okay let's let's do this you know like
let's record all the talks in all almost
all the meetups in Singapore and then
when people come we just tell them that
hey we got reckonings of every single
talk and now you have no excuse so so
this two-person like has been like quite
special to me and I at the end we got a
chance to organize this git branch event
together which is kind of cool quite
nice and it's it's a very special like
thing for me you know like being able to
collaborate with the people who I
appreciate and stuff like that and okay
so I i just kinda I want to mention I
really I'm really thankful to the option
because because of him I get to organize
my own meet up so I go to a lot of
meetups and suddenly I organize one
which is kind of kind of cool so for all
these years I've been like trying
thinking of organizing a meter because
it's kind of like you know I want to try
but there's so many meetups out there
like haha man so co pjs is kind of like
you know first copies like it's a word
for coffee it's a local coffee thing so
when you order coffee it's like like
like you know like like the coffee that
you know right copy is like a local
version of coffee so it's actually
different with different tastes
different flavors different portions of
caffeine yeah and kind of like it's just
a play the word play kind of thing so
copy Jess you know like it's just a
social gathering no talks know anything
no presentation no no no free food so we
just go to a cafe and we talk so it's
kind of like get brunch but smaller
version of it so it feels cozier and
smaller groups means you know you can
you know talk in a better way like go
karting soco pjs or the website and we
go to a lot of pieces a lot of cafes we
discover a lot of cafes we just
sometimes so there will be a bunch of
students from su TD Singapore University
of Technology and design okay and and
then sometimes you will be like like not
just JavaScript people JavaScript engine
is it can be like iOS can be anyone so
it's really open for any like-minded
people and if we just hang out and drink
coffee I think like Thomas appeared
twice i read you like it is a second so
yeah so sometimes you just hang out and
drink coffee and ring
sometimes I like organized this special
meet up so that guy in the red is a well
with a more ouch not sure if i pronounce
his name correctly so he sighed the
creative socket i/o creator of next GS
now GS anything so sometimes like people
come and then like hey you know I want
to know about the community in Singapore
okay fine let's do this copy Jess just
for you and then we'll find a place and
you'll go to that place and we eat yeah
and talk it's that simple and then I
kind of like you know I don't just
organized meet up this copy just meet up
I also pain stickers I print t-shirts
and give it for free like this year I
kinda printer around 60 t-shirts for
like 60 people for free I also help with
other conferences not about this contest
also how other conferences I design
logos for this great rubyconf conference
which is like a ruby conference I also
design like sometimes I like do weird
things like designing stickers for iOS
conf yeah I do design so yeah and then I
also voluntarily print stickers for the
our local meetups here singapore CSS and
singapore GS for free what you keep
saying free okay yeah so I kind of like
you know do this I kinda like oh okay I
can't I do this you know for for like
few months now sometimes I'll be like
asking myself in a light why am I doing
this so I kind of like so there's a
point of time I'll ask myself oh my god
why am I doing this so if I you know and
and I don't really have the answer I was
like oh why am I doing this is so tiring
you know like you know I print teachers
i did i send these t-shirts to other
people and we have to like get the
stickers and give you the other people
way and then I got this part of
stickers and then it's all user ID to
print again and I oh my god this is so
tiring and then organizing meetup is so
tiring and going to meet ups is so
tiring and I'm still doing this I don't
know why and and I'm not the only one
actually there are a lot of people among
us perhaps like some of us would do the
same thing you know like I know as I
said I know a lot more people who do the
same thing in the lights just on Michael
assignee they try to be website is to
help other people the record Michael
record videos for other people some
people like organized meetups for other
people and sometimes you know you get
free food in meetups and sometimes you
ask yourself you know the free food
where does it come from is it sponsored
or is it from from your own money you
know that kind of thing so after all you
know like I kind of like found the
reason yeah it's kind of like it's
pretty hard to find a reason for some
reason so it's kind of like very hard to
find the purpose of what I'm doing it's
kind of like like breathing you know
like when you breathe you know you don't
really think about why your brief
anymore it's like so so you know it's
just it's like so natural you know you
don't even think about it and the reason
is actually very simple so it's all this
a positive feedback basically just all
these tank use all this all this like oh
my god you save my life kind of feedback
that kind of thing you might get it from
from your emails you might get it from
your facebook whatever you might get it
from anywhere or people write articles
saying that you are awesome that kind of
thing so it's actually very simple these
two words means a lot you know like it
kind of like keeps you going and that's
really cool you know it isn't you don't
have to do that much you know that's why
sometimes like it's great that we go to
organizers and
say thank you to them and and that
itself is kind of like enough you know
like it doesn't have to be a lot it
really means a lot it like actually that
two words seriously so give and take so
sometimes I feel like some of us might
have had taken things for granted we
always kind of I think most of some of
us like take a lot sometimes like you
know when you use a javascript library
you know like jQuery or you know react
and all that stuff and sometimes like
you go like that say like lodash or
whatever all right all these websites
you know they have really nice
documentation really nice read nice
really nice articles like well
documentation some people have podcasts
or screen cars so many things and then
sometimes you should just stop for were
and think like who write all this
documentation how much time did you
spend writing all this documentation you
know seriously and that's kind of like
that's all right and and we start to
like take these things for granted you
know like all these things that people
do for us and we just use it and we kind
of like don't give back sometimes so so
my point is that sometimes it's great
that you we put some time into giving
back sometimes I even a simple creating
a deep hot issue kind of thing you know
if you found about report it if you like
see a typo and read me make a pull
request sometimes that simple little
help makes a difference so you can do
more than that you can give talks on
whatever you know like yeah there's so
many ways of doing things you can write
articles help people teach people and
see like it's always like about the
people for me I realized that almost
everything we do is always about people
like seriously everything
like if you be a Prada you know it's
always about like you know making a
product works for our users when you be
a JavaScript framework is always about
people using your framework when you
create a new browser spec browser
specification or the CSS back you want
people to use your you know your
implementation it's always a lot of
people you know like from from your
families your relatives your colleagues
people outside of your work basically
meetups conferences and sometimes you
know like it's kind of like you know
everything is about people you know like
seriously and it's just just amazing
like anything about it and here i would
like to before I finish this I'll just
want to quote a winning limb not sure if
you guys know her she's like the best
storyteller ever like for me she's a way
better storyteller than me so we need
writes a lot about it in her website she
writes a lot about all this like things
like life about things about people
about depression about mental health
about a lot of things it is quite
difficult that is quite rare to see like
people who are like so brief to write
about all these things you know like
usually we just don't talk about it and
everything is just you know hidden right
even like the title of this talk is kind
of stolen from an article so it's called
breeding connections should totally read
this if you are interested so she kind
of like right snail like this you know
about her experience with flight
connecting people and stuff so at the
last of this last part this article i
would like to say this quote so she
wrote this we were all very different
individuals from vastly varying
backgrounds and life stories with
divergent trajectories and hopes but all
that didn't matter when we all breach by
the work we all love to do me possible
by the lack of a physical distance
across
than zeros so beautiful right thank you